I sent out a tweet,
which I normally,
you know,
don't.
And so I sent it out to me.
Here's the tweet,
here's the tweet that I actually set up.
It was to the notorious MMA,
which is Connor.
I said,
stay outside the first three rounds.
Don't overcommit strikes mostly jabs.
Get booed by the crowd,
doesn't matter.
Frustrate,
frustrate,
can be forced.
Bad shots,
tire him out in the fourth start stepping up the striking in the fifth,
let it go and finish him.
Good luck John Cavenaugh at John Gavin.
I tagged his coach because his coach,
well,
okay,
now people are going,
well why were you rooting for Conor McGregor?
And some people went a little crazy.
Like why are you when he's a bad sets,
a bad example for the sport and all that.
So
actually the reason is because I've communicated with coach Kevin,
uh,
a decent amount on Twitter and little dms and all that and just,
you know,
he,
he just has been kind of like a cool guy.
And here he was going into coach his fighter in the biggest fight of,
of Connor's life.
And you know,
just because we've had that little commerce that we've had conversations on
Twitter a bunch and I just threw that out there like two hours before.
I mean we,
I was watching the first fights when I threw that out there.
I didn't know,
the really funny thing is John Calvin was texted back or he,
he tweeted back copy.
So he actually read it and then responded,
which is pretty crazy.
Um,
so,
so anyways,
because I have had a little interaction with coach John Kavanagh,
I felt like,
you know,
hey,
I'll throw this out there also.
You know,
Hans,
Hans is like boys with Connor,
right?
And Hans is my boy.
So I was,
you know that that association,
There's association,
you know what I'm going to be like,
Hey,
Hans is my boy and he has been for a long time and he's Bros with Connor.
And so I just,
you know,
like again,
so,
so people are,
why did you,
why are you voting for this guy?
Win?
So there's that whole thing.
Now th th the other odd thing about this is you have a striker versus grappler.
Who do I root for him,
striker versus grappler crap.
I always root for the grappler and I know that factually and statistically the
grappler has the advantage because grappling versus striking,
the grappler wins most of the time.
How can you go the distance with this argument?
Sure you can took it all the people that all the times that as Stryker is
actually a good grappler and then they don't use their grappling,
but they use their grappling only to defend from being taken down.
Chuck Liddell the,
and there's a bunch of,
and there's countless guys that you can now name that knocked people out and
we're known for their standup.
But what they really were,
their base was that they were a good restaurant,
couldn't be down.
So,
but generally,
striker versus grappler the striker,
and this is what I talk about from a self defense perspective,
right?
If,
uh,
if you're a good striker,
the,
then that means you can run away.